[Applaus]
so sehr dass du die neuen schützling die
die gestern angereist ist diese 11 das
ist ein gerät der folge waren so sage
ich in den kurven hatte
wenn die jetzt raus kommt mal probiert
mal bei der was man die bombardier so
mit meinem charme der fußball die herren
aus der hand wird sinken
morgen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist das idyllisch hier der weiß-blaue
himmel die grünen wiesen diese herrlich
frische luft ja diese wunderbare
hügellandschaften diese berge und täler
einfach schön ja einfach schön ich habe
auch sich auf eine postkarte thema
postkarte ich hätte bei mir um ein
zimmer riesengroße postkartensammlung
wenn sie die vielleicht interessieren
wird dann könnte man doch jetzt
wollen sie mich ja blöd anmachen sie als
bayerische berg oder war gottes willen
ist überhaupt nicht meine art würden wir
morgen gut sie bei mir überhaupt nicht
und man das langweilt echt total
er fragt sich sowohl auf den
[Gelächter]
da schauen sie jetzt was so spricht
nämlich frauen haben da können sie noch
einiges lernen vom set das nämlich noch
ein echter kavalier der alten schule
[Musik]
[Applaus]